Sikhism is the world's fifth largest
religion a Sikhs uniform right a beard
and turban and all the articles of faith
when I wear them I'm representing
equality justice fairness I'm telling
the world that this is what I stand for
and this is what I will fight for a Sikh
would rather lose his head than lose his
turban
I'm simearth boxing I'm captain in the
US Army and I'm also seeking when I
found out that I could not serve with
the Articles of Faith that was a shock
to me six and military service go hand
in hand
my great-grandfather served in war one
for the British Indian Army there's no
conflict between what six valleys are
and the Army Values I started my
military career at West Point when I was
18 I knew I was going to make a big
decision of walking away from articles
of faith the grooming standards as far
as shaving more codified so that
everyone the military soldiers looked
the same and I was standing in line
right outside the barber shop and
thinking well here it is right and I sat
down and and the ladies of the
barbershop were surprised I have long
hair I hadn't heard always my back I
don't know if they understood what was
going on my entire life was changing
everything my self-image everything was
being shattered and that's when I had to
make a decision right and the decision I
made was I want to choose to serve my
country and figure out a way to come
back to my articles of faith later on
it was after I met the two gentlemen who
were wearing their articles of faith and
were in the army and I learned that
there is a way to request religious
accommodation I was simply asking for
what I believe were all my rights and
March 31st was when I received the
permanent accommodation and I had to
pause anything
ten years later ten years later it
finally happened the first day that I
wore my uniform I was my beard turban it
was an unreal unreal feeling when I look
at the mirror now I feel a sense of
pride and completeness my two walls have
come together